all right here we go we bought this Lego
Death Star used because it's out of
print and we asked the guy to not
totally take it apart and this giant box
arrived you have no idea what is really
inside sub boxes Wow that spiral-bound
it's no joke so it's pretty precarious
how was the drive for carry-on it's like
both to the delicate and heavy it
wobbles for like five minutes after you
put it down that's how like good okay
you stay away from this yeah I'm about
to get into my black ninja suit there's
nothing that makes you feel better it's
a ninja spirit
these parts the first to get very icy
out of this nothing to see here I feel
like I'm being suffocated came to you
step into the light ok there we go I'm
not gonna lie I'm nervous excited well
this thing is gonna explode 3 2 1 go
holy gone Oh so incredibly satisfying I
see myself